as models predict higher levels of death
there are still no answers on reopening
strategy the cost of shutting down
continued amount and Ruth Bader Ginsburg
is hospitalized I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show the Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by expressive VPN
surfed the web with peace of mind signed
up right now and expressive VPN calm
slash man before I begin I want to take
a moment to give a shout out to all our
advertising partners who help make this
show possible obviously turn down
economic times it is very difficult for
everybody particularly people who are in
the viewing audience and the listening
audience to patronize our advertisers
they really appreciate it we really
appreciate it we got to keep business
going in this country and our
advertisers make it possible for us to
continue to bring you the news and
commentary you want each and every day
speaking of which right now it is fairly
obvious that the markets are volatile we
don't know what the future is going to
hold one thing that we can fairly bet is
that at some point the government is
going to have to tax or inflate its way
out of the debts that is currently
sustaining this is why you should be
diversified at least a little bit into
precious metals over 26 million people
have now lost their jobs upward of 30
actually from the economic fallout of
coronavirus even with the stock market
having a slight recovery we don't know
the long-term impact of this many
workers being displaced all at once
that's only going to be felt over time
we have no idea what's going to happen
next so what exactly would be the
prudent thing to do well diversify think
of the position you would be in now if
you diversified into gold or silver a
little bit earlier well you can still do
it right now and it's a smart idea to at
least be diversified some before May
31st with a qualifying purchase Birch
gold will help you do this and give you
a free emergency kit as well this
backpack is absolutely loaded with
everything you can't buy right now so
safeguard your savings with Birch gold
they will help safeguard your family
like they did mine no obligation you got
nothing to lose to take that first step
I trust the folks over at Birch gold
I've known them for quite a while Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau don't wait until the market drops
again to protect your hard-earned
savings can get that free emergency kit
again check them out over at Birch gold
group all you have to do is text Ben to
47 47 47 diversified today again text my
name Ben Jew 47 at 47 at 47 that's my
name Ben to 47 47 47 ask all of your
questions to my friends over at Birch
gold group and then get started
diversifying your asset base alrighty so
the big question obviously
in all of this cover 19 situation is
where we go from here and nobody seems
to have a good answer to this and the
easy answer is we just do what the
science says but as I've said the
science doesn't answer these questions
the science is merely an input that you
put into whatever formula you are using
to determine the output right science
can just give you how many deaths they
expect to happen if given particular
factors but they don't tell you how
you're supposed to weigh the value of
those deaths against the value of the
entire global shutdown of the economy or
they can't really tell you how many
people are gonna commit suicide how many
lives will be ruined how many women will
be the victims of domestic abuse because
of all of this how many kids will have
exacerbated mental conditions because of
all of this there's no way for the
scientists to tell you this and I
understand in difficult situations when
we're looking for some level of peace of
mind we want to think that there are
these experts out there this group of
unnamed experts we're gonna solve all of
our problems for us the fact is they are
not the unnamed experts are not going to
solve all of our problems our help they
can't even solve their own problems
example remember Neil Ferguson - Neil
Ferguson is the guy behind that famous
study from Britain that suggested 2.2
million deaths in the United States from
Kovan 19 now it turns out that those
numbers are probably gonna be off by at
least one scale of magnitude even if the
United States were to see
extraordinarily heavy levels of death in
the United States over the coming year
the numbers are never going to reach 2.2
million they're just not going to hit
2.2 million we've seen 70,000 deaths to
date even if we opened up everything
which nobody is advocating even if we
opened up everything willy-nilly let all
the old-age homes just be invaded by
Koba 19 the number of dead in the United
States is not going to be 2.2 million
there's no other study that supported
that 2.2 million number ok well Neil
Ferguson was the one who put out that
study over at Imperial College it was
widely derided by people from Oxford
University - even the University of
Washington as it - hi will now Neil
Ferguson has been fired ok the tsiyon
but not because the science was wrong
not because his studies wrong by the way
he had also been the author of a study
about hiv/aids that it suggested a death
toll way above what it eventually ended
up being he'd suggested the bird flu was
gonna be significantly more deadly than
it ended up being the nice thing about
being a modeler is that you never get
penalized for having a model that is too
dire you only get penalized for having a
model that is too sanguine about the
situation if you're Paul Ehrlich a
University of Berkeley and you suggest
in the 1960s that billions will die I'll
die of global starvation and then none
of that materializes in fact the
opposite happens you still have a job
University of Berkeley if you suggest
that everything is going to be fine and
then a billion people die of starvation
then you lose your job so anyway this
guy didn't lose his job for the bad
modeling into pea really instead he lost
his job because he broke social
distancing rules to meet his married
lover which is just a delicious little
side treat in all of this so Neil
Ferguson had had stumped for vast
lockdowns across the UK except when it
applied to his married lover who is the
mother of two who had stopped by his
apartment and they did not engage in a
social distancing according to the UK
Telegraph Neil Ferguson allowed the
woman to visit him at home during the
lockdown while lecturing the public on
the need for strict social distancing in
order to reduce the spread of
coronavirus the woman lives with her
husband and their children in another
house so good times over in Great
Britain and again that doesn't mean that
his models were were necessarily wrong
what made the models wrong as the models
were wrong not the man was shtupping a
married woman during his during his off
hours but it does speak to the idea that
there are a lot of experts out there who
are telling you to social distance who
are telling you that it's imperative
that you lock down who are not in fact
obeying these rules themselves the name
Chris Cuomo springs to mind lecturing
everybody about not leaving home while
biking around and in and presumably
infecting everybody within a six-foot
radius in any case there are new models
out and the new models are suggesting
elevated levels of death that of course
is not a surprise and anybody who's
telling you that it's well it's it's a
surprise is being a fool of course
they're going to be elevated risks of
death when you start to reopen the
economy everyone recognises this every
single human recognizes this but if you
recognize this then people yell at you
because we're supposed to believe that
there is a policy out there a unicorn
policy that allows us to not completely
tank the entire world economy until the
end of time and also saves every single
life that's not a possibility and if you
mentioned that there are trade-offs of
policy as I've been saying for a while
and this is my Bugaboo right now is that
nobody will honestly discuss the
trade-offs of policy so instead we have
stupid conversations about if you don't
like my policy it's because you want
people to die like that I'm sorry that
is complete idiocy and and nobody
actually believes that nobody actually
believes that let me give you an example
of this kind of logic that is that is
being used right now and then we'll get
to some of the new studies so Andrew
Cuomo yesterday he was talking about how
you make the calculation in New York to
re-open and he said the
human life is priceless well on a moral
level of course a human life is
priceless of course a human life is
priceless
but on a political policymaking level we
make risk calculations about the risks
we are willing to undertake in public
life literally all the time all the time
every elements policy is like this if
Andrew Cuomo really believed in public
policy terms not in moral terms in
public policy terms that you have to
mitigate the risk to every human life
down to zero
he could never discuss reopening because
there is no bar that would be they would
be low enough to clear for that I'd say
here is Andrew Cuomo yesterday
suggesting a human life is priceless
period but if that were the case you
could never reopen including an upstate
New York including in rural areas
because anytime you tell people they can
leave their homes you have increased
their risk so here is Andrew Cuomo
yesterday this is again the if it just
saves one life logic is not political
logic it is it is simply posturing and
demagoguery here is Andrew Cuomo
yesterday there's a cost of staying
closed there's also a cost of reopening
quickly that is the hard truth that we
are all dealing with and let's be honest
about it and let's be open about it and
let's not camouflage the actual terms of
the discussion that we're having and the
question comes back to how much is a
human life worth to me I say cost of
human life a human life is priceless
curried ok but he doesn't actually
believe that right no nobody believes in
public policy terms that a human life is
priceless truly now a human life is
priceless in moral terms in meaning that
we have to prohibit murder right we have
to prohibit people have said when it
when I point this out then public policy
we actually calculate the value of human
life sign actuarial tables right we
actually do this it's called quality
adjusted life years it is ace is it
achieve it is a chief factor in every
calculation we ever do about public
policy because if we actually believe
that every human life was quote unquote
priceless in public policy terms we
would put you in a plastic bubble and
leave you there and feed you through a
feeding tube presumably but when we cut
but when it comes to protecting human
life from others predations
right that would be like abortion for
its
sample then of course there's no
countervailing cost in terms of stopping
people from killing other people right
you may think that there's a priority to
a woman being able to kill an unborn
child I do not think that that is a
priority
I think the priority is saving the
person's life okay that's it there's a
trade-off but the trade-off there does
not look like the trade-off with regard
to destroying the entire American
economy for example which would which
would involve the deaths of presumably
hundreds of thousands or millions of
people and cost you hundreds of millions
of people as well right when you outlaw
murder there presumably is a
countervailing cost outlawing murder
namely the murderers go to jail right
but that is not a cost that that stacks
up against the loss of human life when
we when it comes to public policy making
every human life is priceless in the
sense that you cannot deliberately take
the life of another human being but in
terms of what levels of risk are we
willing to tolerate as a society in
order to live free there the answer is
well it's not quite priceless because
you are then asked to value your own
life and we as a society are asked to
make the decision as to what levels of
risk we're willing to tolerate for
everybody in the public sphere this is
the question of public policy and so it
is a cop-out for Andrew Cuomo to say
every life is priceless when it comes to
policymaking because again he doesn't
even believe that if he believed that
then he wouldn't be opening up at all
there'd be no situation under which you
could open up and so this has become the
go-to argument of people who don't even
want to have a discussion about
reopening or how to reopen a responsible
fashion this is how you end up with this
idiotic tweet with 30,000 34,000
retweets from Kumail Nanjiani and
Nanjiani and guy from Silicon Valley I
guess he's in one of the new Marvel
movies if they eventually would go back
to the movies he tweeted out after weeks
of careful preparation planning and
strategizing most of the country has
landed on the following approach let's
just open it all up and see what happens
not a single governor has settled on
that approach not one not one there are
zero people who have settled on that
approach I mean this is like come on
come on nobody's talking about this but
the way that people talk about this in
order to avoid the discussion is by
suggesting that the alternative to lock
downs are completely opening it up
without thinking about how to protect
the elderly without think about how to
protect nursing homes without thinking
about how to protect the vulnerable
literally no one is discussing that no
one but at some point one of the
conversations that we are going to have
is again
level of risk are we willing to tolerate
and in past episodes I've talked about
the need to make those risk calculations
with regard to everything from the the
number of kids in public schools to the
speed limits right if you wanted to
prevent deaths and in every life or
quote-unquote priceless in public policy
terms you would lower the speed limit to
two miles an hour because elderly people
in 16 and 17-year olds are
disproportionately killed in car
accidents we don't do that we tolerate a
certain level of risk in life Toleration
of risk in public policy does assume
that we can value certain economic costs
against against the additional risk that
people are going to hurt themselves this
is why you buy insurance insurance
companies do this for a living every
single day this is what they do okay so
this raises a question about the new
model so this is really interesting
stuff there is a new model that is out
from the Wharton School at the
University of Pennsylvania this is being
reported by CBS local they say governors
in Pennsylvania New Jersey and Delaware
have a lot to consider before fully
reopening if they open so quickly isn't
that could result in more deaths
according to a new model from the
Wharton School reopening states
economies certainly comes with the cost
and that could result in more deaths but
some economists argue not only can you
put a value on human life but they urge
elected officials to do just that when
making policy decisions right because
literally every policy decision does
calculate out how much it is going to
cost to do X right and that cost can be
calculated the entirety of human life
cannot be reduced to a dollar number
obviously but when you are talking about
reducing economic activity dollar
numbers or quality of life to dollar
numbers you are now taking a bunch of
things that are larger than dollar
numbers and you're reducing it to dollar
numbers so that you can actually make a
calculation because otherwise you simply
cannot do public policy so Alex aren't
on a senior analyst at the Penn Wharton
budget model he says the economic costs
have been enormous we are suffering
really significant unprecedented costs
as a result of these policies so they
put together this model here is what
their model says scenario 1 you put that
graphic back up because it's actually
useful graphic scenario 1 states
continue their stay at home orders
everybody stays home so what they would
forecast is 117 thousand deaths by the
end of June this is if everybody stays
home right no social distancing is not a
things everybody stays home right we
don't have to worry about people getting
back out ok so this would be 18 point 6
million
jobs lost and by the way the jobs lost
plus whatever cost we then take on at
the federal government level we've
already spent seven trillion dollars
seven trillion dollars hey in reality
you have to figure that if everybody
stays home and we lose eighteen point
six million jobs on a permanent basis
it's not gonna be seven trillion dollars
it'll be fifteen trillion dollars right
we're gonna double our costs but let's
assume that those seven trillion dollars
are enough to tide us over for all of
the job loss the twenty millions job
lost if the stay at home orders continue
until the end of June so 117 thousand
deaths that scenario one scenario two is
the partial reopening right that is
social distancing 25 percent reopening a
restaurants you keep the theaters closed
we keep all the public events closed
they say that by the end of June we'd
have a hundred and sixty-two thousand
additional deaths with 14 million job
losses right so that would be one
hundred and sixty-two thousand deaths if
we if we partially open and then they
say scenario three is all the states
fully reopen right this is the
willy-nilly Kumail Nanjiani suggestion
that people are going for there'd be 350
thousand deaths and five hundred
thousand jobs lost so we would only we'd
save about eighteen point 1 million jobs
right we would lose in additional 232
million at 3100 232 million lives and
we'd save about eighteen point 1 million
jobs so for every life lost for every is
so 200 and so you get about 18 point 1
million divided by two hundred and
thirty two thousand basically for every
life lost you would save 78 jobs under
that calculation right that's the
calculation so this is the Wharton
School calculation now the more
interesting calculation comes about when
you look at what they value human life
okay so pre covered 19 the Center for
Disease Control did this right the
Center for Disease Control actually had
calculations where they determines the
quote unquote value of human life in
economic terms like how much it cost to
the economy if somebody dies when they
are young for example and other federal
agencies their baseline was roughly on
average ten million dollars a person but
a human life is worth about ten million
dollars right that is that is the
calculation not from me this is from the
CDC and other federal agencies okay so
if you if you actually use that
calculation for a second what that would
suggest is that even if we only spent
seven trillion dollars which we are not
going to understand Aereo number one and
we saved approximately two hundred and
thirty-two thousand
lives from scenario three where
everybody just goes willy-nilly back out
to work that would mean that you were
spending about sixty million dollars per
life in order to save each one of those
lives based on the economic class which
is six times what the calculation is for
the CDC in terms of value of a human
life now again maybe that valuation is
wrong but we should at least acknowledge
that the valuation that we are using
unspoken in unspoken fashion is way
higher than any other valuation ever
used in human history when it comes to
policy making along these lines if you
do a partial reopening and you were to
lose an additional forty five thousand
lives you would still be spending about
42 and let's assume it would cost five
trillion dollars which of course is not
true but let's assume it cost five
trillion dollars you're still spending
bout forty two million dollars per life
saved then scenario threes been zero
dollars right because presumably most
people keep their jobs and so you're
coming in underneath that ten million
dollars so the answer if you were
looking to spend about ten million
dollars to save each life would be
somewhere between the partial reopening
and the full reopening it is also
necessary to look at how much money you
would have to spend per job saved so in
terms of amounts of money that you'd be
spending per job saved if you were
looking at the the amounts of money is
seven trillion dollars right over the
two hundred and thirty two thousand
additional lives then what you would be
looking at presumably is per job saves
you'd be spending not all that much
money right you'd be spending all you'd
be spending a lot less money per job
saved in terms of the worst case
scenario so is this a case for the worst
case scenario hum oh this isn't the case
for reopen it all up because again
there's certain basic things that we
obviously should be doing it is also
necessary to mention in these models
that these models only go through June's
and the numbers could balloon way
further than this right this is only
through June it is also necessary to
mention that there's no guarantee that
the lockdowns through June end up with a
lower total number of deaths
remember everybody keeps talking about
that flattening of the curve stuff right
the flattening of the curve was designed
again to prevent the overwhelm of the
healthcare system so I'm gonna draw the
curve for you one more time because
people seem really not to understand
this in the media
okay the flattening of the curve was
supposed to prevent the curve from being
overwhelmed it was not supposed to
change the area underneath the curve
hey and this is why everybody is being
kind of dumb about all of this so this
is what the curve was originally
supposed to look like right here was the
big curve this is the big curve right
here on the if you can watch this you
can see it on the left side of the on
the left hand let's see it be your
left-hand side of the page on your
left-hand side of the page you can see
the big spike the line is the medical
capacity and then here is the lower
curve the lower curve is supposed to
stay below that line great the actual
area the shaded area that I'm about to
shade in right here okay that is the
number of deaths total okay that is the
number of deaths total order the number
of infections total rather okay so this
is not so the number of infections total
is going to be the same over time
okay recognize that so if this thing is
as deadly as it's gonna be and we don't
overwhelm the healthcare system when
people were worried about what
specifically this area above the line
these would be excess deaths but in
terms of total number of infections the
total number of infections gonna be
exactly the same so when you look at
those models that look through June that
is not enough you would actually have to
look at the model through the extent of
the year and then decide on economic
class here these are all the
calculations that actually go into the
calculations but it's important to note
them because no one is willing to
discuss this stuff out loud it is
politically unpalatable to discuss this
stuff out loud which means that the
policy is gonna end up being really
stupid that's what it ends up the it
meaning but the policy is gonna end up
being super dumb because if you can't
discuss out loud
the actual considerations that are going
in what you end up with is on the one
hand the posturing of people who suggest
that they're going to save every life
Andrew Cuomo is not going to save every
life the dummy just started cleaning the
subways five seconds ago it's May guys
it's May they shut down everything in
March except the subways the chief
incubator for this thing they only
started cleaning the subway systems at
night now like yesterday but he's saying
he's out there saving every life of
course that is not true of course that
is not true but we've reduced our
conversation to the dumbest possible
point we're gonna start having to have
these tough conversations about when des
reopen what the actual costs are what
are the monetary costs whether we are
using anything besides gut it's so funny
people say data and science and and
Trump is using his gut about reopening
I'll tell you who's using their gut
about reopening people who refuse to
even have the conversation about
mathematical values that are used in
every other actuarial investigation of
every other policy in human history
it's frankly like it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous you have to make these
calculations because there is no other
way to make the calculations otherwise
you are just reduced to my gut is that
we should just stay in until when I
until what happens men what are the cost
well doesn't matter every human life is
priceless
that is not policymaking that is
posturing political posturing he'll get
some more of this in just one second
first let's talk about the reality which
is that the future is really really
unpredictable and this is why you need
life insurance very important for you to
insure against the possibility of bad
things happening in the future you no
can do that life insurance for you life
insurance companies who do actuarial
calculations about how much to pay you
in case god forbid you should plot you
can take advantage of their acumen by
going to policy genius.com policy
genius.com is an insurance marketplace
there's a big demand for life insurance
right now so if you're looking to get
life insurance here's how they can help
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies in one
place it takes just a few minutes to
compare quotes from the top insurers to
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you could say 1500
bucks or more a year by using policy
genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork and the red tape for free
they're in contact with life insurance
companies every day monitoring
developments and helping customers
navigate every single step there's no
reason to wait on something as important
as life insurance head on over to policy
genius right now they will find you the
best rate and handle the process
completely you can stop worrying about
life insurance get back to baking your
sourdough bread or adopting a pet or
something but you can get rid of the
life insurance thing on your insurance
checklist right now by going to policy
genius com head on over to policy
genius.com
okay so president Trump is getting all
sorts of flack for mentioning the fact
that it is indeed time to open and that
we are going to have to figure out how
to reopen in decent fashion the Texas
governor Greg Abbott is taking a hit
so here's Trump yesterday mentioning
yeah we can't keep this closed forever
it's kind of time to open a viewing our
great citizens of this country to a
certain extent and to a large extent as
warriors
they're warriors we can't keep our
country close we have to open our
country one day they said we have to
close our country well now it's time to
open it up and you know what the people
of our country are warriors and I'm
looking at it I'm not saying anything is
perfect and yes well some people be
affected yes well some people be
affected badly yes but we have to get
our country open and we have to get it
open soon okay Trump is correct about
this and he says the shutdown is gonna
kill people too yes this is also true
this is obviously true apparently the
Cullens to suicide hotlines are up
1,000%
apparently people are not going in for
chemo treatments those quote unquote
elective surgeries that actually help
people's quality of life including the
elderly those are not being performed
medical personnel are being laid off
across the country when these hospitals
are not even near a capacity because
people are not performing elective
surgeries here's Trump mentioning all
this but apparently is very bad to
mention this if you mentioned this
you're a bad bad man president Trump's a
bad bet like this is the dumbest form of
our political conversation it is so
stupid because no alternative has
actually been provided none
I'm sorry lockdown is not an alternative
full time lockdown forever until the end
of time with no schooling with no summer
camps with no work none of this is a
reality but it's very easy to sit in
your corner and just shout you don't
care about human life you don't care
about human life as we'll see in a
second there's a National New York Times
columnist who's suggesting the problem
here is American freedom I have a
feeling this person had a problem with
American freedom long before the
pandemic here's President Trump talking
to how the shutdown will kill people to
the fact that we're letting people go
and go to their jobs they have to do it
you know if they help people any longer
with the shutdown said you're gonna lose
people that way too and you already have
I'm sure but between drug abuse and I
mean they say suicide a lot of different
things there's no wind just so you know
there's no great win one way or the
other
okay so president Trump is right about
this also the Texas governor Greg Abbott
who's ripped up and down because he was
on a phone call apparently and on this
private phone call Greg Abbott suggested
that you know what if we reopen that's
going to add risk yeah no bleep Sherlock
like this is the basic premise of a
lockdown the whole prop well if they're
going back to work doesn't add a risk
why did we lock down seriously like that
that would be the question the counter
question is
we not supposed to expect additional
risk when we go out of course we're
supposed to expect additional risk the
question is which populations are least
likely to suffer from the additional
risk I will give you the answer young
people healthy people children that's
your answer those people are not very
like when I say not very likely I mean
exorbitantly unlikely to die of covin 19
and to pretend that everybody is equally
susceptible or that you cannot open in
responsible fashion namely by starting
by protecting nursing homes which have
been responsible for 40 to 50 percent of
all deaths in the EU and in California
in New York lot of people have been
dying in their apartments because
nursing homes in New York City are not
like a huge thing that they're kind of
bigger across the state because of the
heavy population but the fact is that if
you protected the nursing homes you
would you would you would lower the
number of deaths across the United
States overall and certainly in Europe
by anywhere from 20 to 50 percent which
would be near miraculous but Greg Ambu
is being ripped up and down for
recognizing that there are additional
risks when you open things up ya know
again why is any of this a shock and
when people are ripping on abot for this
or ripping on Trump for this it's
because they do not wish to come to the
grips with with the reality of public
policymaking instead they're involved in
this idiotic political calculation that
suggests that we're all supposed to
pretend the public policy has no
trade-offs this is my Bugaboo he drives
me up a wall it's what makes non
partisan issues like risk calculation
into partisan issues when you suggest
the people to die in order day that's
true you got ripped up and down for even
acknowledging this we're supposed to
pretend that it's not gonna lead to an
increase in spread yes we get it so
what's the alternative I can't I keep
asking this to people I've provided
several different possibilities here
none of them involved full lockdown
forever those possible
range from the controlled Avalanche
strategy proposed by Israeli scientists
in which we protect the elderly would
protect the most vulnerable and
everybody else is encouraged to actually
go into the population and interact and
to obtain an immunity to it because if
you are young and healthy again it is
very unlikely the sense of your damage
to you and you move toward a herd
immunity that's basically Sweden's
strategy in controlled fashion meaning
that you still do some social distancing
but the reality is that over time you
actually want people to get this so it
moves through the population get hurt
immunity that's possibility number one
possibility number two you go out you
continue to socially distance you wear a
mask you do protect the nursing homes
the economy really takes a hit like a
more severe hit than it would otherwise
and it takes longer to reach hurt
immunity but at least you haven't killed
that many people in terms of the
increased risk in the amount of times it
takes to develop a therapeutic or
vaccine rise that you're hoping for a
real change on the ground those are a
couple possibilities I'll tell you
what's not a possibility keeping it
going like this and you know who's not
evil I'm sick of the media portraying
people who's evil this way you know he's
not evil the person who wants to go back
to work
this is such crap it's utter absolute
nonsensical crap it's not only
quote-unquote rich and white people who
will do well reopening okay so the
former Obama CDC director said that the
only reason people are reopen is because
they're rich and white what absolute
sheer unmitigated garbage you know who's
you know he's getting this right now
like right now a lot of the essential
workers you know what's happening with
the essential workers many of them are
disproportionately the essential workers
particularly in the health care industry
like nurses or delivery people
disproportionately minority and poor
those people are already out interacting
those people are already getting coded
the people we're talking about going
back to work are largely not blue collar
workers and the people who are finding
it very easy to say shut down forever
are people who can sit in their basement
with a with a step-and-repeat behind
them on CNN and get paid I have it easy
I can lock down basically forever I can
I mean the reality is that my job does
not require me to leave my house but let
me tell you let me tell you story that
ain't true for 90% of the population it
is not rich white people who benefit
from the ends of the lockdown the rich
white people are rich they are living
they have money the people who benefit
from the end of the lockdown are all the
people who are losing their jobs all the
people who can't keep their small
business afloat this is the most
demagogic nonsense dr. Richard
or former acting director of the CDC
what's not being done we don't have the
testing capacity now to know where this
disease is we haven't scaled up the
thousands and thousands of contact
tracers that we need we don't provide
safe places for people to isolate or
quarantine if they're identified as
either having an infection or being
content we are saying if you have money
and you're white you can do well here if
you're not good luck to you
that is such nonsense it's such absolute
nonsense we should be protecting people
if they get sick they should be able to
go home they should get paid leave from
the government unemployment insurance or
whatever it is
no one wants people to die we have to
acknowledge that there are trade-offs to
public policy but apparently we're never
going to acknowledge this and this is
how you end up with the stupidity of a
Dallas salon owner getting seven days in
jail for reopening okay in Texas where
Greg Abbott is supposedly willy willy
willy nilly reopening everything that's
not what's happening that's not what's
happening there's a woman named Shelly
Luther she defied local and state orders
and a judge's restraining order she
operated her business during the
pandemic what exactly did she do she
went into her salon Salon alamode and
she opened it and she was taken into
custody her business was deemed
non-essential which of course is
nonsense the government should not be
able to deem your business non-essential
it was forced to close March 22nd after
the country after the county enacted its
stay at home order she reopened the
salon April 24th tore up a cease and
desist letter from the county judge clay
Jenkins the temporary restraining order
was signed April 28th she said she'd not
earned any income since the county
stay-at-home order was set in March she
said that she applied for one of the
federal loans but it didn't receive
didn't receive it for weeks she said I
couldn't feed my family my stylist
couldn't feed their families so before
Luther was sentenced to a week in jail
the judge gave her an opportunity to
apologize and promise not to reopen at
her salon until she was allowed to do so
and here was her answer in court I've
never been been in this position before
and it's not someplace that I want to be
but I have to disagree with you sir when
I when you say that I'm selfish because
feeding my kids is not selfish I have
hair stylists that are going hungry
because they'd rather feed their kids
so sir if you think the law is more
important than kids getting fed then
please go ahead with your decision but I
am NOT gonna shut the salon okay and she
she by the way she was willing to
socially distance inside the salon she
was willing to do mask-wearing inside
the salon the only difference between
what she was jailed for and not being in
jail was one week because by the end of
the week
guess what Texas is doing they're
opening up all the salons and social
distancing and with masks wearing this
is just this is nonsense I'm sorry this
is absolute nonsense and it does betray
for a for a certain group of people in
the United States a real feeling that is
antithetical to to freedom itself I'll
give you an example of this from a
columnist at the New York Times
momentarily first let us talk about the
simple fact that the job market right
now is a bit of a mess if you need a job
the best place you can go is zipper
current if you are looking to hire the
zipper career is going to be the best
way for you to find the best qualified
employees zip recruiter is doing deeply
important work right now at a time when
the job market is in complete flux as we
move back into normalization zip
recruiters gonna become more and more
important go register over there right
now at zip recruiter comm slash work
together as if recruiters Apple send you
up-to-date job openings so you can be
one of the first to apply and if you're
actively hiring zipper critter will
invite candidates to apply to your most
urgent roles making it faster and easier
to reach the people you need by
connecting people who need jobs and
companies that need people zip recruiter
is working with all of us so we can
continue to move forward so we should
work together as if recruiter comm slash
work together deeply important to get
people who need jobs connected with
people who want to hire them zipper
career doing that every day they can
make your business better they can make
your job experience better by allowing
you to get the job that you need go
check them out right now at zip
recruiter comm slash work together
zip recruiter comm slash work together
they are focusing on the important
things in the middle of the most
volatile job market in American history
zip brokerage comm slash work together
already we're gonna get to more of this
because again undergirding a lot of the
arguments or non arguments about public
policy here is an actual antipathy
toward American freedom I'll give you a
perfect example of this in just a moment
first I want to take a moment to tell
you about the Daily wires newest most
exclusive membership tear the all-access
insider the all-access insider
membership to here is our premium is our
premier
of membership all access members get the
benefits of our other membership tiers
including an ad-free website experience
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library access to the shows mail
bags and the full three hours of the ben
shapiro shot along with dedicated
editorials from moi all access members
also get other amazing benefits
including of course these singular
irreplaceable leftist tears tumblr they
also get to join live exclusive online q
and A's our daily wire discussion
feature available on both the website
and the daily wire app you also get to
participate in all access live that is
our brand-new interactive programming
featuring one of the daily wire host as
we hang out with you each night and
we're just goofy at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. Pacific earlier this week it was me
wearing a Darth Vader mask and singing
show tunes I know I know things are
getting weird out there I will be
joining you again this Friday afternoon
so head on over to daily wire.com slash
subscribe to join The Daily wires
all-access Club with a new membership or
an upgrade get 10% off with coupon code
Shapiro that is daily wire.com slash
subscribe see you there you are
listening to the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
all righty so when I said that there are
people out there who seem to be rooting
for the lockdowns because they don't
actually like freedom very much Charlie
waters all is an opinion writer at large
for the New York Times he has a piece
today titled open states lots of guns
America is paying a heavy price for
freedom and he uses the same logic with
regards to coronavirus that he uses with
regard to guns namely you shouldn't be
able to own a gun as a normal
law-abiding citizen because apparently
this raises the risk of gun violence in
your state he mentions a from a friend
of mine after my editor over at
broadside books Eric Nelson is my editor
he tweeted someone poke holes in the
scenario we keep losing a thousand to
two thousand a day to coronavirus people
get used to it we get less vigilant as
it slows very spread as it very slowly
spreads by December were close to normal
but still losing 1500 people a day as we
took passed 300,000 dead most people
aren't concerned Wars all said this hit
me like a ton of bricks because just
have plausible it seemed the day I read
Nelson's tweet 1723 Americans were
reported to have died from the virus and
yet their collective passion was hardly
mourned after all how to distinguish
those souls from the 2097 who perished
the day before or the 1558 who died the
day after and then he says there's a
national precedent for Nelson's
hypothetical America's response to gun
violence and school shootings he says as
a country we seem resigned to
preventable firearm deaths so just like
the reality is that the that freedom of
guns means that some people get bad guns
but also that you can protect against
bad people he thinks that that is bad
right the American freedom to keep and
bear arms is bad because according to
him it means more dead Americans now you
can make the counter-argument which is
that the people who have guns are
getting them in medicate and using them
for crime are not people who tend to
abide by the law in the first place
right the banning assault weapons isn't
going to be effective but even taking
his logic right even taking his baseline
logic which is that additional risks in
American life come with additional
American freedoms the end point of his
logic is that if you want no risk there
can be no freedom and he's ok with that
right that's actually what he's ok with
he says left to their own devices states
are opening up many anxiously and with
little idea as to how it will play out
the White House could lean on governor's
to slow the reopening process or urge
caution until we can fully establish
tests and trace strategies that have
worked in counts in countries like South
Korea in
the administration seems to be cheering
on the reopening while internally
preparing for a substantial increase of
loss of lives an internal document based
on modeling by FEMA projects the daily
death toll will reach about 3,000 On
June 1st a 70 percent increase from the
May first number of about 1,750 along
the same lines on April 30th the day
after Trump told Americans the virus was
going to go it's going to leave it'll be
gone NBC News reported the federal
government had ordered more than a
hundred thousand body bags and and then
he again likens this to to gun control
policy suggesting well if we just banned
the freedom to keep them bear arms there
would be less gun deaths same way if we
just ban freedom totally then presumably
there would be less coronavirus deaths
alright so I'm gonna take up the other
half of that argument which is freedom
does come with additional risk freedom
comes with additional risk and that's
what freedom is called that is a reality
and that doesn't mean that we should not
mitigate that risk right I've been in
favor of bans on the even using his
logic I've been in favor of bans on
machine guns for example and I've been
in favor of federal criminal background
checks when you purchase a gun through a
federally licensed firearms dealer even
the NRA is for that okay but what he is
talking about basically is you know it'd
be great if we banned all guns
presumably by the same logic if we
banned all freedom
there'd be no coronavirus deaths just in
terms of numbers by the way I think that
it is important to mention right here
that if we lose 2,000 people a day from
coronavirus for the next several months
which again there are very few
projections that expect this but let's
say that that happens this will be a
horrible terrible thing that also does
not answer the question as to whether we
will lose that many people in total over
the course of the next 12 months from
coronavirus right there's no alternative
being provided I mean that the fact also
remains that in the United States we
lose approximately 2,000 people every
single day from both heart disease and
from cancer about 600,000 people die
every year from heart disease and
another 600,000 people die every year
from cancer but he says the idea of
freedom I mean this this is really the
root of the debate Charlie Wars well
rights the idea of freedom is an excuse
to serve one's self before others and a
shield to hide from responsibilities if
that's how you think of freedom we
should end freedom right we should in
freedom now I think that people can be
both free and virtuous people can be
free and they can attempt to mitigate
risk for others this is why I think that
we should tranche populations and people
who are
you should go back to work first and if
we think that there's a therapeutic or
vaccine on the way in fairly short order
we should socially distance in order to
restart the economy but also ensure that
we don't have a vast spread before
vaccine can be developed right I'm all
for these things but according to
Charlie waters all the American people
cannot be trusted and thus freedom it
must be ended right you can't be trusted
with the gun as a law-abiding citizen
because the very presence of a gun means
the presence of freedom and the presence
of freedom means more people dying from
gun violence and the same thing is true
of coronavirus the presence of freedom
means more people going out and acting
stupidly and that means we cannot have
freedom at all well that is an argument
that as we used to say in law school
proves too much it proves too much
it is a isn't it it is an insane
argument that essentially argues for the
ending of all American freedom and again
we're beginning to see this in in some
of the petty awful right arianism that
that just cannot last yesterday there
was tape coming out of a Texas SWAT team
raiding a restaurant that was open again
I don't see any evidence in this protest
that people were violating social
distancing protocols that the Ector
County Sheriff arrives in a freaking
tank with a gun turret on top just solid
solid stone
I mean they're going in with actual guns
blazing to people who have an open
business
is it I'm sorry I didn't those people
look like they're super close together
to you or they look like they're 10 feet
apart all right I mean if this is what
is that if this is what coronavirus
lockdowns look like in the end I there's
no policy that's been proposed that
makes this look okay none none and
there's no timeline and there's no
endpoint and there's no actual
discussion of the data and there's no
discussion of any of this because
everybody who wants the lockdowns and is
comfortable with curbs on American
freedom is just shouting at the moon
that every life is priceless without
recognizing that every single element of
public policy is based on the premise
that risks to life are calculable when
it comes to freedoms and prosperity and
all the things that actually make
America worth living in it meanwhile you
got Democrats who are taking advantage
of the situation to say that the federal
government should bail them out of
California as they call for a full
lockdown see this is one of the issues
here is that states are now looking to
the federal government to bail them out
so as the lockdowns continue in states
like New York and in California they're
looking increasingly to the federal
government to bail them out California
has now borrowed from the federal
government to make their unemployment
payments well why should the federal
government fill in California's holes
when it comes to their own unemployment
system truly it's because California is
incredibly irresponsible with it with
its own spending you know how I can tell
this here's what The Wall Street Journal
reports now 3.7 million people have
filed unemployment claims in California
since mid-march California had about 1.9
billion dollars in its unemployment
trust fund mid April down from 3.1
billion dollars at the end of February
the month before the coronavirus upended
the US economy the state's Labor
Department did not immediately respond
to a request for comment California
serves as an early sign of the potential
magnitude of federal assistance that
could be required if states are to
continue paying out jobless benefits it
is more than it is one of more than 20
states and jurisdictions that entered
the current economic crisis without
enough money in their unemployment trust
funds to pay benefits through a
year-long recession according to the
Labor Department data by that measure
California was prepared to make
unemployment payments for just over two
months in the event of a recession two
months so California was deeply
irresponsible decided to blow all of its
money on crap union contracts with
various public sector unions and then no
money to pay unemployment insurance and
now it's up to people in other state
to pay for all of that New York did the
same thing they blew out their budget
and now they don't have enough money to
pay for the stuff they should have had
the money to pay for and and now they're
turning to the federal government for
the bailout and if they get those
bailouts you note that incentivize it
incentivizes governor's to spend doodles
of money they never have because they
know that at the end it's too big to
fail California is too big to fail New
York is too big to fail now this has led
demagogues like Andrew Cuomo to suggest
that the federal government needs to
step in and fund the states so here's
Cuomo yesterday suggesting that New York
needs to be funded now last I checked
New York has um the is the second
richest citizen body in the United
States after California and they tax
them at exorbitant rates and yet they've
run out of money incredibly quickly
could that have to do with their crap
spending habits and the bad union
contracts they signed maybe it has to do
with that but according to Andrew Cuomo
it's up to the federal government to to
bail them out of course because you can
always cast all responsibility to
defeated the federal government states
need funding states need funding a for
testing tracing B states need money
because we have a deficit after the
corona virus and you have not been given
ever stopped every so you don't have
enough right all right right if they
don't pass a piece of legislation Chris
but hold on a second they are now they
were supposed to do it this week they
are going to come back next week if they
don't pass a piece of legislation
gameover gameover and then he says you
know what should happen here Republican
states are the ones taking out more
money in the Republican states are the
ones who are taking out more money from
the kitty okay this is he what he is
saying here is so economically
illiterate it's almost beyond
comprehension
you look at the Republicans who now say
well we don't want to help the
democratic states they are actually the
states that have been taking more every
year Virginia Maryland Kentucky senator
Mitch McConnell is Kentucky 37 billion
dollars more every year Alabama Florida
everything is about Florida why because
it's a swing state and we're in an
election year I get it okay this is not
true okay the way that he is calculating
this is he is taking the tax dollars
paid by New York citizens to the federal
government and then the tax dollars
received
New York citizens from the federal
government New York is a
disproportionately wealthy state
California is a disproportionately
wealthy state it is not that the federal
government takes money from the state of
California and then only gives money
back to the state of California what he
is talking about is the fact that
Kentucky for example is a
disproportionately poor state so there
are fewer people who are paying in
federal income tax to the federal
government and there are more people who
are receiving directly but at no point
is the state government actually act as
the intermediary they're basically
you're saying that poor people are
receiving more money from the federal
government than rich people that is 100%
true and that rich people are paying
more money into the federal government
than they are receiving from the federal
government that is also true another
thing that happens to be true the people
who are disproportionately receiving
money from the federal government tend
to vote Democrat studies show this so
what the hell is he talking about what
he's attempting to avoid is the reality
of the situation which is the reason
that New York is in trouble despite the
richest population in America outside of
California despite that New York is in
trouble because Andrew Cuomo couldn't
get his spending habit under control
that neither could anybody else in New
York and the same thing in California no
New York is not the is not the victim of
a benefits payment scam here it's
ridiculous yeah but but this is just
demagoguery to avoid responsibility
which is what Cuomo is apparently really
good at it is unbelievable to me the man
remains a popular governor despite the
fact that only now in May is he starting
to clean the damn subways at his
original move with the nursing homes was
a look an old person who has covered 19
let's send it back from the nursing home
genius move Andrew Cuomo genius that guy
is great he's great at his job but round
2 Sampson Florida in Greg Abbott in
Texas very very bad at their jobs and
Brian cabal just too awful at his job
incredible incredible okay time for some
things I like and then some things that
I hate so there is a a new movie on
Netflix that is that is a fun watch it
is I will not say it is you know the
world's most fun watch it has some great
action sequences is really what this
comes down to it's Chris Hemsworth
running around Dhaka Indonesia and
basically just destroying everything
there's one about 20 minute action
sequence that's getting a lot of
attention in this movie extraction
because it is supposedly done in one
shot it is not done in one shot
obviously they game the system they're
moving through windshields and and there
are some subtle cuts obviously but it's
really well choreographed
the basic premise is basically the same
as man on fire guy who is hired to
extract a kid who's been kidnapped and
then things go wrong and now he saw us
to extract the kid who's been kidnapped
here's a little bit of the preview best
thing you could do for that kid would be
a good boy
because in a chopper and get your own
but you could leave the kid behind are
you gonna leave me in the street
[Music]
grabbed all of my best now hang on as
tight as you can
okay so the the actual best scene in
this movie is actually a scene where
Chris Hemsworth is forced to UM to face
down a herd of child soldiers because it
is is just hilarious watching a six foot
four Nordic God basically throw around a
bunch of 13 it's kind of absurd that the
whole movie is kind of absurd I mean
it's one of those some how he was
bulletproof like he gets shot and hit by
a car in one sequence and the next day
he's basically fine he's up moving
around totally cool
takes about nine shots to take him to
anyway the movie is that the movie is
worth the watch if you're into action
flicks so you can go check out
extraction time for some quick things
that I hate alrighty so first of all
there is the story that Ruth Bader
Ginsburg has been treated for a minor
sin she had minor surgery for a
gallbladder infection we wish the best
to anybody who's in a position of public
policy obviously we wish for her
long-term health I also hope that she
retires but she's not going to retire
but yeah we wish for her health so that
is that is some bad news but in terms of
real things that I hate so people are
going nuts today they're going nuts
today over Betsy DeVos Betsy DeVos is
very evil you know
Betsy DeVos the Secretary of Education
the reason Betsy DeVos is super evil is
because according to the Washington Post
she plans to release as early as
Wednesday her much anticipated final
rules governing how schools must
investigate sexual assault allegations
bolstering the rights of the accused
according to people familiar with the
matter in its broad outlines the
sweeping regulation is unchanged from
the proposed version released in 2018
though the more minor adjustments made
throughout according to one person
familiar with the matter who is
unauthorized to comment publicly and
spoke on condition of anonymity the
rules will give universities in colleges
a clearer but controversial roadmap for
handling emotionally charged conflicts
that often Pit one student against
another there are plus less replaced
less formal guidance issued by the Obama
administration that was friendlier to
those making the allegations that is a
wild understatement the original Obama
issue IRRI allegations did not give
students the ability to confront their
accuser or even to rebut the allegations
they basically a set they basically made
it so that an allegation was tantamount
to guilt under the new rules college
students accused of sexual assault and
harassment must be given the right to a
live hearing and the ability to
cross-examine their accuser as much as
the proposed rule directed before you
didn't even have the right to confront
your accuser and you weren't
the right to a live hearing you were
literally not given the right to a live
hearing so someone accuses you of rape
and you say no that wasn't right that
was consensual sexual congress and the
and the the old rules basically said you
have no ability to defend yourself also
the rules also defined sexual harassment
narrowly limiting it to contact that is
both severe and pervasive not just one
or the other well again that makes sense
because if the pervasiveness is you look
nice today that's not sexual harassment
okay if the pervasiveness is you keep
grabbing people's asses repeatedly then
it's got to be severe I mean first of
all that sexual assault right if you
actually physically grab someone that's
an assault that's not just harassment
but if you say something deeply sexual
and you do it and it's it's severe and
it is pervasive then you can be
disciplined in one change the regulation
explicitly adds dating violence and
stalking his allegations that must be
investigated so it's actually made this
thing stronger in some ways de Vos said
the new rules would restore balance in a
system that had been skewed in favor of
the accusers now this prompted people on
the left to become very very angry very
angry because their suggestion is that
title nine regulations should basically
allow people with the allegation alone
to go ahead and condemn folks to the
purgatory of guilt forever
that was the basic allegation and people
were tweeting about that today so that
there were actual tweets that people
were issuing about how terrible it was
to allow to process in cases like this
which of course is completely crazy
right Catherine Lemone who is a civil
rights advocate and chair of the u.s. CC
US CCR and a legal affairs secretary for
a gavin newsom the governor of
california she said
Betsy DeVos presides over taking us back
to the bad old days the predate my birth
when it was permissible to rape and
sexually harass students with impunity
its excuse me excuse me this just says
you have a right to defend yourself it
doesn't say that you are not you are not
punished for sexual assault or sexual
harassment but Catherine on the moan
says today's students deserve better
including fair protections consistent
with law and this is just I'm sorry this
is insanity this is insanity
but it's particularly in sanity given
the fact that the Democrats continue to
defend Joe Biden because by Joe Biden
standards by his own title mine
standards
dude's guilty as sin I here's Nancy
Pelosi yesterday saying you know what
I'm not going to answer any more
questions on Joe Biden I'm not gonna
answer any more questions on these Biden
allegations because we're done here I
mean what is there more to say weird
because under title 9 regulations Joe
Biden's guilty as sin and he'd be
expelled from college for this if not
for plagiarism I have said I am proud to
support Joe Biden for president I
believe him when he says it didn't
happen but I also believe him when he
said let them and look into the records
and that's what they should do but I'm
not going to answer this question again
I will just say I have every confidence
that Joe Biden will be a great president
of the United States which has great
confidence it's a 19 year olds who are
getting accused of sexual assault
allegations they don't have the right to
defend themselves according to Joe Biden
and Nancy Pelosi in the entire
Democratic infrastructure but 80 year
olds while running for president those
people we just kind of let off the hook
right I mean they're and they they can
just say I didn't happen it didn't
happen it and we're basically done I
mean that is that is an incredible thing
it's an incredible thing and it
demonstrates that when it comes to due
process the Democrats just don't believe
in it what Democrats actually believe in
is that due process should only exist
for people that they like and people
that they like include generally people
who are not part of the quote unquote
power superstructure right so if you're
a rich white male like Brett Kavanaugh
then you deserve no due process this was
an actual case made about Brett
Kavanaugh people saying he's a rich
white male he had a he had an
entitlement complex and that's why he
doesn't deserve to be on the Supreme
Court and they say the same thing about
19 year-old college students right rich
white males in college the most
privileged among us we needed to but if
you're a rich white privilege male like
Joe Biden and you're running for
president then we sort of let you off
the hook due process is specifically due
process because it equally applies to
everyone
equal protection of the law is equal
protection of the law because it is
supposed to apply to everyone the fact
there are so many people on the Left who
want to turn these standards on their
head because they believe that equal
protection of the law is inherently
unequal
because some people are less well
situated than others some people are
richer than others therefore those rich
people don't deserve equal protection
under the law that's French Revolution
off with their head kind of stuff and
that is exactly what Democrats have
proposed with regard to title 9 they're
defending Joe Biden at the same time
that they're ripping on exactly the same
kind of protections Joe Biden will have
to rely on
in order to survive these sexual assault
allegations that's pretty incredible
okay one more thing that I hate so the
Lincoln project is a is a group of
people led by George Conway right and
George Conway of course Kelly Ann's
husband there's a group of people who
were anti Trump Republicans in 2016 and
never got over it and have decided
better to say but many of the members of
the Lincoln project literally suggested
they would vote for Bernie Sanders
before Donald Trump which doesn't seem
super conservative to me I'll just put
it out there I don't think that's a
super Republican view that you'll vote
for the you know the Communists before
you voted for Donald Trump and it
actually advocated for the Communists to
win some of these people were doing this
so they put out an ad within the last
couple of days this is the most
depressing anti-american ad I have seen
in quite a while they call themselves
the Lincoln project apparently Abraham
Lincoln would have approved of ads that
basically suggest that America is an
absolute utter complete hellhole where
where death is vast and everyone is
impoverished because of Donald Trump
here is the ad I mean I've yet to see a
more depressing ad than this one with
the economy in shambles more than 26
million Americans are out of work the
worst economy in decades
Trump bailed out Wall Street but not
Main Street this afternoon millions of
Americans will apply for unemployment
and with their savings run out many are
giving up hope millions worry that a
loved one won't survive kovat 19 there's
morning in America and under the
leadership of Donald Trump our country
is weaker and sicker
or okay what I mean okay we're all a
little stressed right now is this super
helpful is this super helpful by the way
if this is the tone Joe Biden goes for
to get skunked because seriously
Americans are not going to abide being
told that we are richer and poorer and
that we are sicker and poorer and worse
off and everything is terrible and we're
all dying of covet 19 what a misfire
what a dramatic misfire that's gonna add
that you make seriously when you don't
care who gets hurt in order for Donald
Trump to be thrown out of office because
the reality is that we're all a little
worried right now you know be good some
hope some hope would be good and you
don't have to credit Trump in creating
that hope george w bush didn't when you
put out a little video about it even joe
biden hasn't been doing this the fact
that these folks are so vindictive about
trump that they're going to blame kovat
19 on trump that they're going to show
pictures of body bags rolling out of
morgues and blame that on Trump it's
perverse it's absolutely perverse again
Andrew Cuomo's the governor of New York
guys Gavin Newsom is the governor of
California the death centers of this of
this country are all happening in blue
areas not just because of bad governance
but also because those are heavily
populated areas this this is such a bad
strategy but there are a lot of people
who are embracing it because you got to
blame Trump for everything speaking of
which a lot of people blaming Trump
today because President Trump is
supposedly thinking about closing down
the coronavirus task force and this is a
very bad thing no let's let's point
something out when it comes to the
federal government you don't actually
need task force's ok task forces are a
way to posture to the rest of the rest
of the world task forces our way to say
I'm taking this seriously it's like when
Obama would set up a green jobs czar
write who'd set up bizarro well he's
taking it seriously there's a czar now
though this art was pretty serious last
time around so this hour will be super
serious we'll set up a new Department
Department of Homeland Security now
we're serious the same staffers were
already in the government there were
just in different departments he's a
good PR for Trump to disband the
coronavirus task force in the middle of
the coronavirus no it's not this is dumb
PR it is it's dumb there's no rationale
for it but on a practical level is the
federal government going to stop caring
about kovat 19 because the coronavirus
task force has been quote-unquote
disbanded no dr. Fazzio will still be
meeting with trump dr. Burks will still
be meeting with Trump all these people
will still be meeting with Trump they
will still be doing press conferences
but this this prompted all sorts of
angst yesterday all sorts of it the PR
of kovat 19 for the media is far more
important than the actual policy when it
comes to the actual policy they don't
want to talk about it because the actual
policy would force them to acknowledge
trade-offs in policy they don't like
that instead they go to the PR because
the PR can be black and white and PR is
always trumped is awful and evil and
everything he does is terrible so that
means it's supposed to be a super big
deal that he's quote-unquote dissolving
the task force the meetings in the
Situation Room of the White House have
been shorter the task force no longer
meets every day according to NBC News
doctors deborah birx and anthony voucher
are still expected to be at the White
House daily but other members of the
task force may be present less
frequently however sources familiar with
the matter noted the task force did meet
on Tuesday and President Trump said
we're now looking at a little bit of a
different form than form his safety and
opening will probably have a different
group set up for that
he said the mission accomplished is for
when it's over we there was no mission
accomplished but apparently if you call
it for example the reopening task force
and it's exactly the same people and
you're evil and bad so here's Jim Acosta
Jim Acosta and all over Donald Trump
yesterday about the task force you need
to continue to meet with the task force
to get this scientific expertise we will
have certain people I think that as far
as the task force Mike Pence and the
task force have done a great job but
we're now looking at a little bit of a
different form and that form is safety
and opening and will will have a
different group probably set up for them
are you saying mission accomplished no
no no no the mission accomplishes when
it's over its again the fact that Acosta
is trying to pin on him the the mission
accomplished war in Iraq banner that was
flying after the United States invaded
Iraq and destroyed the Iraqi army that
he's trying to say he's trying to get
him to gaff right this is all the media
are intent on doing right now they do
not care at this point about which
policy is pursued so long as the policy
pursued is anti-trump that's all if
Trump actually wanted to open up the
country tomorrow he'd called for a
national lockdown on infinitum
seriously the media would flip on a dime
if Trump just said you know what we got
to lock this thing down forever until
there's a vaccine
immediately the media would start
reporting on the economic dispossession
happening across the country and they
would start taking seriously the fact
that people are losing their livelihoods
because for the media it's all about
Trump and all about the media and it is
not at all about a responsible
discussion of public policy at least for
those in the political media who are
outside you sort of
health industry alrighty we'll be back
here later today with two additional
hours of contents otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis clever and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
why douse key technical producer austin
stevens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SIA vets
audio is mixed by micro Romina hair and
makeup is by Nika Geneva the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you